[Musique]
bienvenue sur France 7 il est 15h nous
sommes le vendredi 25 juin 2032 un pic
de température a été atteint aujourd'hui
avec
50°gr quand on anime un exercice de
c'est un peu le parallèle
miroir parce qu'on av fait une une
expression de besoin par rapport à un
besoin de travailleur
essentiel
les tunnels sont des lieux
particulièrement intéressants parce
qu'ils sont naturellement rafraîchis ils
sont stables en température toute
l'année c'est pas une diminution de
quelques degrés par rapport à
l'extérieur c'est qu'il fait à peu près
20 degrés toute l'année à
[Musique]
l'intérieur
c'est une crise qui est prévisible don
on sait qu'elle va arriver cette
exercice Paris 50°gr c'est un exercice
qui s'inscrit dans la refondte de la
stratégie de résilience de la ville de
Paris qui vise à anticiper les crise les
préparer les préparer avec les Parisiens
faire que les Parisiens soient acteurs
de ces moments difficiles de manière à
ce que voilà il y ait pas d'interruption
d'activité et que on puisse vivre dans
une quasie
[Musique]
normalité le but ensuite c'est de créer
des sous-événements comme l'arrivée des
pompiers ici pour gérer des
problématiques qu'on pourrait avoir dans
des lieux refuges comme du monoxyde de
carbone donc là on va voir les pompiers
qui arrivent ici avec des bonbonnes de
gaz qui peuvent intervenir dans les
meilleures conditions pour faire une
levée de doute ici de monoxy de carbone
pour être sûr que le lie refuge est un
lieu refuge viable pour des enfants ou
des personnes
âgées du coup les enfants étit hébergé
et mis à l'abri dans un tunnel et ils
ont présenté différents symptômes
notamment de la température de la nausée
et des maux de tête donc ils ont été
évacués du du
[Musique]
tunnel
the fact of the matter is that climate
change is here it's here to stay we are
moving towards zero carbon reduction
emission targets but in the mean time we
need to learn to
adapt
[Musique]
donc